talk about losing someone like take off
man takeoff was obviously a great guy he
was one of the nicest dudes you could
ever meet in the music game I mean
you've known him for a long time that
had to be a big loss for you
yeah you know it's my brother like my
best friend not my twin you know
everything
so it really [__] me I really never
lost nobody like that close
so just like and [__] me it's just like
you know you might just wake up and
start crying and see a picture stop
crying Here song and start crying
especially him like he was such a just
it felt like a very peaceful genuine
person yeah super nice guy every time I
met him he seemed like you know he was
and also like really one of the most
iconic bit influential rappers ever if
we think about his flow and just like
when I think of the Migos floor I think
I think it'd take off legendary for sure
yeah it's crazy man like uh for you like
was
um was that like a wake-up call to kind
of like you know because you never know
when you're gonna lose somebody these
days especially in the music game you
know
like I don't know if it was a wake-up
call but it's like you know it's just
crazy bro like
it's just [__] me up you know
like
you don't know how to respond to
something you don't know like you don't
know I don't know does it make you move
a little bit differently in terms of how
you're moving around and you've had
situations where you've had some serious
[__] that couldn't went left we could
have lost you you know what I mean that
we know we all know about you know but
is when something like that happens do
you kind of like reassess how you're
moving who's around what you're into you
see me like I don't be with people I
just be by myself a [__] won't
even know where I'm at because I'm not
with nobody but right you know it's like
it's always it's always dangerous doing
anything in the rap and right being the
rapper
you got all this [__] for sure whatever
especially you moving around all that
jewelry